what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the big three the three
strongest hero students in all of you eh
and the students considered to be the
best in all of Japan these three are of
course me Leo Takata aka la million
Tamaki ammaji ki a ke sun-eater and Neji
Hado aka nana-chan hers is clearly the
most fierce hero name of them all in
this video I will be giving you all the
information that you need to know about
the big three including a breakdown of
their extremely powerful quirks if you
want to learn more about the big three
or you just need a refresher as you
watch season four of the anime
definitely stay tuned to this video if
you enjoyed the boku no hero content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
seriously though the way that YouTube
works now if you don't make sure to turn
on all notifications you are going to
miss a lot of our videos that's just the
way it is feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest MHA news and updates
quick heads up this video will include
information on the background
personality and quirks of each member of
the big three I will not spoil what
happens to them after they are
introduced and I will not spoil how the
arcs that will be covered in season four
of the anime will end but depending on
how much of the anime you've seen some
of the information may be new to you so
with that in mind proceed with caution
you have been warned the big three is
the name used to describe three senior
students from UA high school because
high school in Japan lasts for only
three years since they also have three
years of middle school this means that
the big three are in their third and
final year at UA Nigeria and Tamaki are
in class 3a and medial is in class 3b
the three of them are 17 years of age
when they're first introduced and they
are 18 at the current point in the story
the big three are distinguished from the
rest of the students that you
because they are the absolute strongest
hero students in the school even before
graduating from high school they are
already stronger than many existing Pro
heroes and the big three are said to
have the potential to become some of the
highest rank Pro heroes in all of Japan
we first meet the big three when they
are asked to explain the hero work-study
program to the students of class 1a and
we learn more about them as several
members of the main class 1-a cast find
themselves working alongside members of
the big three during their work studies
first let's talk about the one and only
media Toccata also known as la million
who is easily one of my favorite
characters in the entire series I love
this guy so much if he had been the main
character of the story instead of Deku I
would have been totally okay with that
aside from looking like a jacked
Japanese Tintin which is pretty awesome
in itself miryo also has a great
personality and I just love it whenever
Mario is on screen he is always positive
high-energy and he loves to act silly
and joke around but always in a friendly
way he has never mean-spirited miryo
always seems to have a smile on his face
and his positive energy rubs off on the
people around him which is one of the
reasons why sir Knight I thought that
Mireille was the best candidate to
become the new symbol of peace after all
meit's retirement all night was also
known for always being positive and
smiling even in the most difficult
situations and this positive attitude is
what inspired people and imbued them
with hope and enthusiasm after all -
retirement many people became worried
that no one else would be able to fill
in all my shoes and this would lead to
social unrest and instability but beyond
just the ability to remain cheerful and
positive in difficult situations the
more we learn about myriad the more he
becomes a fascinating and impressive
character and the more we understand why
he was a top contender for becoming all
might successor when we first meet media
we quickly see that he has an incredibly
powerful quirk that is capable of taking
out all of class 1-a in a shockingly
brief period of time however as we later
learn meteos quirk was actually
extremely difficult to control and
virtually impossible to master
Media went through countless hardships
and struggles in order to learn to
control his quirk so that he could use
it to one day become a hero if they were
in meteos shoes the vast majority of
people would have given up on mastering
such a difficult quirk a long time ago
as a hero media is committed to saving
as many people as possible and even
though he knows that he can't save
everyone on his own he chose the hero
namely million to symbolize the fact
that he wants to save a million people
the name of meteos quark is permeation
and it allows his body or specific parts
of his body to pass through solid
materials including walls floors and
ceilings
he can also dodge enemy attacks by
making his body or parts of his body
permeable which means that the enemy's
attacks will simply pass through him
while he is in a permeable state the
media cannot breathe use his senses hear
or see anything which poses a major
challenge in terms of using the quark
effectively but media worked incredibly
hard until he learned to control the
quark and he also learned to effectively
teleport from one place to another using
his quark well it's not exactly
teleporting but if he suddenly turns his
quark off while passing through an
object his body will then be immediately
ejected from the object so quickly that
it looks like he is actually teleporting
from one place to another through
training media is able to control the
direction of the ejections allowing him
to rapidly appear exactly where he wants
to go although meteos quark appears to
be extremely overpowered when used by
media as I mentioned earlier permeation
is actually a very difficult quark to
use and virtually impossible to master
it is only due to meteos unparalleled
determination and unmatched work ethic
that he was able to learn to use his
quark so effectively and became as
strong as he is today it isn't the quark
itself that is overpowered meteos hard
work and daily struggle and sacrifice
made it as powerful as it is today now
let's talk about Tamaki ammaji ki aka
sun-eater this man takes the saying you
are what you eat to a whole new level
but before we learn about his quark we
learn about his extremely shy and social
the awkward personality tamaki is a
timid and quiet person and the pressure
of being one of the strongest hero
students in Japan is sometimes a bit too
much for him to handle despite his
incredible strength and intelligence
Tamaki often lacks confidence in himself
and he is known for being nervous in
social situations but despite these
challenges
Tamaki is indeed incredibly powerful and
he has shown himself to be capable of
great bravery when the situation calls
for it one of Tamaki's greatest
inspirations is me Dio who also dealt
with great challenges before he could
become the person he is today Tamaki's
friendship with me Ryo has helped him
become more confident and determined as
a hero the name of Tamaki squirt is
manifest and it allows its user to
transform his body in an interesting way
namely Tamaki can manifest on his body
the property of everything he eats such
as for example turning his fingers into
tentacles after eating octopus he can
manifest the properties of multiple
different substances at the same time
and combined them on his body so for
example if he eats both octopus and crab
he can manifest a claw and tentacles on
his hand at the same time creating a
more complex combo weapon but that's not
all if he consumes objects that are not
necessarily food such as a small piece
of crystal Tamaki can manifest hardened
crystals on his body the ability to
manifest the properties of the things he
consumes only lasts for as long as he
has the objects in his system so to be
blunt
until he poops them out in that sense
stomach he kind of reminds me of hawk
from the seven deadly sins and of course
we know that both of these characters
are among the strongest in their
respective series so it makes perfect
sense because he is able to combine
various different things that he eats as
part of us quirk Tamaki does his best to
consume a variety of different useful
foods every day so that he can always be
ready in case he needs to use his quirk
despite the fact that he is still a high
school student
Tamaki was able to use his quirk to
defeat multiple experienced villains at
the same time all on his own and finally
we have Neji wretch on the cheery
intelligent and
girl with an impressive quirk that can
take down even the biggest and strongest
opponents to say that nedra is energetic
would be an understatement because magic
work actually enables her to turn her
own life energy into shockwaves that she
can then use against her opponents she
can also use the shock waves to move
around quickly and jump through the air
as if she were flying
so her quirk is both very strong and
very useful beyond pure physical
strength because she is such an
outstanding student magia has been able
to unlock the full potential of her
quirk and use it in ways that someone
who is not as determined and dedicated
would not be able to do however nature
desk work does have some pretty
significant drawbacks in order to use
her quirk neji I must use up her own
energy so the amount of power she can
generate in any given time is limited
and if she exceeds this limit negative
will collapse from fatigue
obviously if nej'ta overexerts herself
and collapses in the middle of a fight
it could cost her her life so fighting
as part of a team is usually the best
strategy for nej'ta
I have to say that it can't be easy to
introduce new characters into a story
after over a hundred chapters or over 60
anime episodes and still have these
characters become fan favorites this is
especially the case with a series like
my hero academia that already has an
extremely large cast full of lovable and
epically cool characters however I
really think that holy course she did a
great job with the big three and even
though they're introduced later in the
story I fell in love with their
characters right away all three
characters serve as great role models
for the younger students and all three
characters showed that even the
strongest and most acclaimed students
had to face many challenges and
struggles in order to get to where they
are today at a very young age the big
three have had to deal with the
challenge of mastering their quirks with
the challenge of having confidence in
themselves and being a positive
influence on others and with the
pressure of being considered the
strongest and best hero students and
then having to live up to those
extremely high expectations the big
three are a major source of inspiration
for Deku and the other younger students
but they are also extremely interesting
characters in their own right they
didn't get to where they are today just
by being lucky you're pretty
they got to where they are today by
working harder than anyone else by
overcoming massive challenges and by
learning from some of the best heroes in
the business so that they could then
pass on what they learned to the younger
generation I absolutely loved the big
three
especially media and I am glad that they
were introduced into the story despite
the fact that so many other characters
were already competing for our attention
in the series let me know what you guys
think are you a fan of the big three and
which of them is your favorite also
which of them do you think has the
coolest quirk let me know down in the
comments I always love hearing from you
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications feel free
to hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest MHA news
and updates I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime out pro patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldress on hell crews
stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including Ingrid ah alone
Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun and yah boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]